خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين لم يبدا هذا
القصر قصر
حادثه العنصريه التي طالت مساعده الملكه
اليزابيث الرحله حتى اعلنت منصه نتفليكس
عن وثائقي هاري وماجن هذا الوثائقي الذي
تصدر عناوين الصحف كافه بلا استثناء وهو
ما قد يتسبب بصداع للعائله الملكيه التي
عاده ما تتجنب الحديث في امور العائله
الخاصه
بوكس
الحلقات الثلاثه الاولى لا تقلوا عن ضجه
الاعلان الترويجي الذي تزامن مع زيارته
ويليام وكيت الى امريكا فاراء ثنائي في
العائله الملكه ستنفرت مؤيديها لاسيما في
وسائل الاعلام
صحيفه المترو ذائعه الصيت والتي توزع في
القطارات سنه هجوما عنيفا على هاري وماجد
سائله اياهما هل تضعان المال قبل العائله
واجابت عنهما قائله انه السؤال الذي لن
يجيب عنه
على صفحتها الاولى ايضا فالى جانب صوره
لهاري والملك الراحله طلبت بايقاف ما
وصفته بالخيانه للملكه اديلي ميل والدليل
الملكه الراحله في حين تحدثت التايمز عن
انزعاج القصر من الوثائقي ومعتضمنه
كينج
من ملاحقه الاعلام لها بحجه ان هذا ما
يحدث لكل اللواتي يرتبطن بالعائله ويتحدث
هاريا فخره بان اطفاله مختلطوا العرق وكيف
انه فعلامه
على العائله حيث تقول انها مهما فعلت
كانوا شيء يجدون طريقه لتدميرها في
الوثائقي يبدو هاري ماخودا بوالدته وبتشبه
بينها وبينما من حيث التعاطف والحنان ومن
حيث الثقه والدفء هل يقول انه سيفعل ما
بيوسعه لتجنب تكرار سيناري والدته مع
عائلته الحاليه هو لا يريد للتاريخ ان
يعيد نفسه وربما ذلك هو المفتاح الذي
ادخله القلوب الكثيرين الذين احبه دائما